Wall Street Journal has a blog out today
in the economics section that says that
a survey has been done that this just
blows my mind 57% of Americans say their
income taxes are too high the problem
with that statistic is only 55 percent
of Americans pay income tax so at least
2% of you are so stupid that you think
your income taxes are too high and you
don't even pay income tax how bizarre is
that see I think if you make more money
it's okay for you to pay more money I
make a lot of money I don't mind paying
my fair share a percent the same
percentage of my income that you pay but
I do have a problem with half of
Americans not paying any income tax half
have no skin in the game none whatsoever
now they pay other taxes I'm talking
about federal income tax you pay sales
tax if you have sales tax in your state
you pay tax on your gas you pay a tax to
get your tags you pay a tax pea tax you
pay attacks you pay tax I get it you pay
taxes but I'm talking about federal
income taxes which we just filed last
week right if you filed your taxes on
time half americans approximately do not
pay anything into that zero many
actually receive money if they didn't
pay anything in but they receive money
when they file their income taxes did
you know that see
I listen I've been broke I've made
$20,000 a year I made $18,000 a year
I've made a lot more than that and I get
it but everybody ought to pay something
even if it's two dollars you got to pay
something
yah-yah-yah to pay something if I make
ten times what you make I don't mind
paying ten times more but I do kind of
mind being the only one paying in fact I
really mind that a lot a lot and then
I'm really resentful and angry when you
know people come out on the extreme left
talking about how we need to increase
taxes on the rich well that's all the
people you're taxing already income
earners are the only ones getting taxed
at all there's a lot of people earning
money they're paying no income tax and
there's a lot of people earning money
that are paying not only paying no
income tax but they're actually getting
money I'd say back it's not back they
get a a check from the government it's
not back because you got to pay it in to
get it back you can pay anything in at
all and you get money you get a check
from the government the Earned Income
Tax Credit look it up you make $30,000 a
year household income you got four kids
you get a check from the government you
don't pay anything in at all now I'm not
mad at you I'll help you I help you all
the time but as a philosophy as a method
of passing laws as a way of looking at
how a people should be governed everyone
should be involved everyone should be
involved everybody should have skin in
the game now I'm not sure we should do
this in America but I'll tell you it
changes people's mindset I just came
back from eleven days in Israel and all
Israelis males serve three years in the
military before they do anything females
two years if you're an Israeli citizen
you serve in the military
you put skin in the game now it's a
little different than money I get it
it's a different issue but here's the
thing if they do that because they're
trying to survive because they've got
enemies on every side and they're trying
to create a cultural icon called
protection a warrior class and they've
done that they are warriors without a
doubt to be respected and if you take
them on to be feared and they it is
because they've been beat on for
centuries Millennials but aside from the
issue of is but the point of that is is
is that every Israeli has skin in the
game in the military in America every
American ought to have skin in the game
taxes you ought to pay something you
should pay something and it's not
because I'm griping about my taxes I'm
going to do that anyway as long as you
buy $20,000 toilet seats and $10,000
hammers and you do stupid but stuff like
you know wildflower experiments and crap
with my money at the federal government
level I'm going to gripe as long as
you're inefficient and stupid whether
it's the federal or the state level I'm
going to gripe at you about that and I
guess pretty much as long as there's
been an over bloated federal government
there's been people like me griping
about it but aside from the fact that I
don't like that it's not that I'm you
know I just think it's it's healthy for
the culture philosophically for everyone
involved to pay some taxes fifty-seven
percent of Americans in this Wall Street
article say Wall Street Journal articles
say their income taxes are too high but
only 55% of Americans pay income taxed
that tells us that somewhere around 2%
didn't even get out of sixth grade I
mean oh my gosh are you really that
stupid
57% say their taxes or two huh that's
everybody that pays taxes and then some
I mean that there's you know it's
unbelievable recent Gallup poll pegged
the percentage of Americans who think
their own federal income tax bill is too
high 57 percent that's up from 51% last
year and it's the highest level since
2001 just before the Bush tax cuts
became law here's the problem just 55
percent of American households will pay
federal income taxes in 2016 according
to Tax Policy Center the US as a set of
deliberate bipartisan policies that
reduce the tax burden of lower income
families and middle income families and
deliver social benefits through the tax
code
the Earned Income Tax Credit always call
it the unearned income tax credit the
child tax credit the standard deduction
and personal exemptions all combined to
zero out income taxes for tens of
millions of households and even cause
you to get a check listen it's not even
a conservative thing with me I'll be
conservative you want me to be
conservative I like most of my policies
most the way I think about things are
conservative I just think it's good for
the culture for everybody to have a have
skin in the game everybody ought to pay
something something they really wouldn't
change the math that much and we just
changed the spirit in the land we should
all be participating this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you